it wouldn't be the oscars without vanity
affairs after party and this year we saw
a slew of bold daring and vibrant
fashion choices as black and white and
bling dominated the color palette for
the blue carpet yeah zendaya traded her
custom valentino two-piece for a fitted
suit by sport max and jewelry from
bulgari while kim kardashian almost
matched the carpet in a sleek blue
valencia gown with futuristic sunglasses
michael b jordan and girlfriend lori
harvey made their carpet debut stepping
out and matching tony ward and reality
couple kourtney kardashian and travis
barker traded their red carpet looks for
something with a little more drip like
literally uh indulging cabana and tom
brown meanwhile sophie turner was red
hot and louis vuitton showing off her
growing baby bomb as she posed alongside
husband joe jonas and shira seemed to be
the trend for the night with anna taylor
joy kristen stewart and lily james all
stepping out in the see-through look
gucci crew jessica chastain made us
green with envy in this bodice number
while dakota johnson looked fierce in
feathers posing with her the lost
daughter co-star maggie gyllenhaal and
haley bieber and zoe kravitz slayed in
san lorenzo
wow one
what was your favorite look that's so
tough i mean everybody can you know what
i really actually really love i'm not
saying this because i love the guy but i
thought steam looked amazing oh for the
show or for the after show
yeah so cool i know even even um
zendaya's look at the uh the oscars was
incredible i absolutely loved it and
then i loved her look at the vanity fair
but i think dakota johnson uh did an
amazing job with it is it dakota johnson
dakota johnson yeah yeah yeah she looks
like the gucci crew yeah so i i mean
everyone look really amazing um and it's
you know what this is it's just like
that feeling before everything that's
happened the last two years you see
everybody on a red carpet and enjoying
themselves i was honestly i was honestly
like
here i am in like my pajamas i know like
seeing what's going down and being like
for the last few years ah like being in
front of a lot of people i don't know i
don't know but honestly watching
everyone step out and look so good i was
like
maybe it's time maybe it's time to take
off the pajamas
people it's time to take out the pajama
pants
i mean do we agree or are the pictures
i'm ready i'm ready yeah i think it was
great i think it was great to see the
fashion out there and and everyone was
invited to vanity fair there were so
many other people that weren't part of
the oscars and it was it was great to
see
people out because people like jordan on
the red carpet because
they're going to get married i think
they're going do you think so i think
that's the way to go i think they're
really really in love survey says yes
but also the vanity fair was will smith
and his family too so i mean
i mean all right oh there's also kim
kardashian was there with that what's
her name julia
fox
right she was there too so what happened
with them
this is the reason we need to be on the
carpet so many questions we're missing
that we're missing it you want to be
there yeah you were watching you were
like i wish i was there there covered
but on the carpet you would have been on
the carpet that would have been like
sangeeta yeah yeah
i love you